[Music]
it's 7 a.m in a pretty victorian park in
north belfast
as parents take their children to school
a steel gate is being unlocked
every day at the same time a warden
opens these gates that separate two
communities from each other
it's called a peace wall
almost 25 years since the good friday
agreement
i've come to see how much northern
ireland has moved on
before i moved to ireland last summer i
hadn't been in belfast since 1994.
i was astonished to find out that today
there are more peace walls separating
communities than ever before
this wall is about one of a hundred in
belfast that have been built since the
1960s
[Music]
the name peace war sounds like a
contradiction in terms
[Music]
the barriers range from simple fences
to towering metal walls that cut through
the city's working-class communities
so i wanted to find out why northern
ireland is having such a hard time
leaving all these physical political and
economic barriers behind
to try to understand all this
i'm going to talk to people from
northern ireland's past present and
future
some who took up arms during the
troubles some who were born since the
cease-fire
and some who are educating the next
generation
their aim
to get northern ireland to stop punching
below its weight
[Music]
this is belfast today
it's busy and vibrant and it's come a
long way since the bombings and terror
of the troubles
but it's still struggling with problems
that are deeply rooted in the past
the linen and shipbuilding industries
that put it on the map even before
northern ireland was created by
partition in 1921 have long gone
by almost any measure today it's a
region that badly lacks the rest of the
uk
part of the history of north ireland has
been events
politically and socially
have often got ahead of economic
problems being addressed and that's been
the case right through the past 100
years
compared with the rest of the uk
northern ireland today is poorer its
productivity is lower and an exodus of
young people seeking better
opportunities is stunting its future
prospects
researchers say young people move away
because of segregation sectarianism and
politics that they believe are stuck in
the past
and then there's brexit which has become
a hugely divisive issue in a region that
overwhelmingly voted to remain
but today's barriers are not just
physical
in northern ireland your name or where
you live can mark you out as being
protestant or catholic
that might once have affected your job
prospects the shipyards mostly employed
protestants for example
during the troubles it could have put
your life in danger
today many people say that the once
automatic reflex to identify people has
gone
but not when it comes to education
look at this chart students here
overwhelmingly go to schools that are
either protestant or catholic only eight
percent of schools are fully integrated
[Music]
in northern ireland even education is
divided so i've come here to visit one
of the very few schools that isn't
dude hi arya hello you're very welcome
the hazelwood integrated primary school
in the wonderful north belfast with a
beautiful backdrop of the kiev hill
shall i take her in the school and show
you some interesting things
maybe i should start off with telling
you
some of the backstory of the school
so about 45 years ago i grew up parents
two of which are still employed in the
school met in a kitchen
and had a dream a vision
as an alternative to segregated
education
as jim the headmaster explains while the
troubles raged in the 1970s some parents
were convinced that education needed to
be mixed
they managed to set up integrated
schools for children of both faiths and
for both nationalist and unionist
communities
the first was established in 1981 but
tensions were so high that there had to
be armed police outside
but times have changed
people may identify as belonging to one
or another tradition but church
attendance even before kovid was on the
wane
[Music]
and mixed marriage is on the rise
jim says northern ireland is still
grappling with hatred and distrust
so this is defaulting we talked about
the sort of the figure that runs to our
community here from
um
and one community on this side and the
second community on that side and we
talked about those things as well so
that's the nationalist community that's
the unionist community like everything
else in northern ireland you know use
very clumsy crude language to group a
whole group of people into one
pigeonhole and that's
that's not only it's on keynes usually
unfair
so predominantly we have a nationalist
community in this a predominantly we
have a unionist community on that side
and and this was a flash point for a
long time
paul caskey from the integrated
education fund says that today these are
safe but not neutral spaces for people
from all sides i'm very proud to say
that today we have 69 integrated schools
educating over 25 000 children and think
of that ripple effect where you have 25
000 children
possibly maybe 40 000 parents and more
grandparents so it reaches out into the
community it shows that it can work
and we've demonstrated that this wasn't
some sort of wacky woolly liberal
group of of people
these kids are facing an uncertain
future
when it comes to jobs productivity and
wages northern ireland is bottom of the
class in the uk
no wonder some people decide to leave
but some decide to come
immigrants started to arrive in northern
ireland in large numbers about 20 years
ago to work in meat processing and the
health service
then a few years later came an influx of
people from new eu member states
attracted by relatively free labor
market access
but the immigrant population is still
tiny and it doesn't make up for the
number of people who move away every
year
a recent survey by pivotal a think tank
found the number one reason people want
to go is sectarianism number two is job
opportunities
carl frampton's way out was boxing
i meet the two times world champion in
tigers bay a unionist area where he grew
up this is a real like
flash point here just so this is tigers
bay my street was the first the first
street in tigers bay and that's the new
lodge their good friend called sam his
brother um
glenn
got got blew up at the bottom of the
street with a paper
that's why carl's mum made him start
boxing when he was seven to keep him out
of trouble
that's also how he met catholics for the
first time
now he promotes integrated education and
sees the results at home it's a better
place than it used to be northern
ireland certainly belfast as well but
it's i think we're still
you know my kids generation it needs in
these damn guys to come through kids
like my daughter who doesn't know the
difference at 11 years old between a
catholic and a protestant but for some
people he admits peace hasn't brought
change fast enough the area if i'm being
honest it hasn't changed that much i
feel like people talk about places being
left behind
just down the road from carl's gym harry
smith and kate clark are trying to get
opposite communities to focus on what
they have in common not what keeps them
apart
it's not easy this was a flashpoint area
during the troubles and it's where the
latest flareup in violence happened just
last year
loyalists are already collecting wood
for a giant bonfire one of thousands
traditionally lit every july to
commemorate protestant king william of
orange's victory over the catholic king
james in 1690
we have communities that rely on
peacefuls for community safety for
feeling safe in their homes at night
what our job is to do is to try and
promote
and engage with those residents who
aren't normally engaged with promote
peace barrier removal re-imaging or
redesigning
but that's easier said than done
kate lives behind steel fences here in
the nationalist new lodge estate over
the road from tigers bay
and what's what are we seeing here these
are the
gates that um
close off dunker and gardens these are
pescates
these
it's like they open at half seven close
at six o'clock and is there no other way
in or out no so if you're in and you've
got to buy something yeah so if you're
in you're stuck you know if you've
you've been living beside a barrier for
20 or 30 odd years sometimes 40 years
you know
yeah it's like a comfort blanket for you
as well
and it's pretty hard to let it go you
know you have to have to show people
that there's another
possibility another
life in northern ireland younger people
don't remember the troubles
older people can't forget them
republicans were fighting for a united
island
and loyalists to remain british
paddy hart has been working for more
than 30 years to rebuild relationships
he says it's too soon to expect things
to have moved on entirely
and brexit is reviving old divisions
lots of the gains lots of the hope lots
of the positives out of the good
fighting agreement
have come under pressure in recent years
because of brexit in the protocol and
the uncertainty that they bring
people then began to begin to
uh move back into the the the the binary
version of northern ireland so um
she has lots of progress um
uh
but incredibly a lot a lot a lot more a
lot more to do but also understandably
given what northern ireland's been
through it would be too much to expect
that um
25 years on
everyone would have left all of what
happened behind pauline hegney used to
work at the europa hotel which was
bombed more than 30 times during the
troubles
her husband carl a catholic was murdered
because he was walking home from the pub
on the wrong side of the road
in those days in 1991 you would have
walked on one side of the road going
down the road
you would walk on the right hand side if
you were catholic
and on the left-hand side going down if
you were protestant
and he was on the right hand side of the
road going coming down the road
and someone was standing in a
just in a doorway along the gas works
wall
and
as carl approached they
the god man
just walked up to him and shot him point
blank range in the stomach
and when he fell then he shot him point
black range in the back but pauline
who's also a catholic thanked the
predominantly protestant police for
taking him to hospital
that was something that
didn't sit well with some people in the
community i lived
and
one saturday night my
car windows smashed and there was paint
thrown around them and everything so
and it was because i thank the rgc
something i don't regret doing
a lot has changed but sometimes the old
orange and green divides resurface
like housing her son is looking to buy a
place with his protestant girlfriend
he's
in a relationship with the wee girl from
the other community in the country and
she could live anywhere with him in any
catholic area
i don't know if he could live in any
protestant area rigid divisions between
communities can also extend to gender
opportunities
but prospects for women aren't always
better
eileen weir has been working with the
shank hill women's center in the heart
of belfast's protestant unionist
community for three decades
today employment rates for women are
stubbornly low and we're not seeing that
peace dividend that that we thought we
would have we need jobs for our young
people common three we've probably about
three generations here that never worked
and never knew what work was
fixing that will help put northern
ireland on a path to higher growth north
island has the biggest proportion of
those with low or north no skills in the
uk
or of any region in the uk
but there's also the problem of those
with higher skills and northern ireland
has the lowest proportion of those who
have a tertiary education so that's
university degrees but also further
education those kind of vocational
qualifications
it's not just about jobs divisions in
northern ireland are all about identity
[Music]
language and sport are two key
expressions of that and they can be
political
you see this area here we ask belfast
there's 80 000 inhabitants and ten
thousand people from here were in prison
jake mcshakish is a former ira prisoner
he now runs a gaelic football club
it's already considered a nationalist
game but here they play in
irish i joined the republican movement
when i was 10 years of age i joined the
youth wing of the republican movement
i always
had a great admiration for the
generations of irish people who had
resisted british rule
and i knew that i was a
captive second class citizen in a state
which was hostile to me at every level
his love of the irish language grew
he perfected it in prison in the
notorious h blocks where 10 ira
prisoners died on hunger strike
irish has long been a political football
a law to give it official status has
been promised but has still not been
passed when jake set up his club all he
asked was that people could kick a ball
and speak irish fluently
today he even has some protestant
players
but identity and culture are complex
and it's that conflation of political
allegiance
with cultural identity that causes a lot
of problems i mean if you go into
the
unionist or protestant community
there are
evangelicals
adventists presbyterians free
presbyterians
non-aligned presbyterians church of
ireland
all sorts of methodists
there's one catholic identity
but there isn't one protestant anthony
it's it's
it's so multi-layered
on the other side of the historic divide
another former fighter is trying to
build bridges
i meet robert williamson in the historic
house where king william of orange
stayed when he first arrived in northern
ireland
robert grew up on a housing estate that
was predominantly paramilitary
but now he works with loyalist
communities to change some of the famous
murals that illustrate the past we would
go to various streets and we talked to
individuals and families and we talked
to local community groups and that and
we try and get a buy-in from them when
you come to a meeting um
and basically say listen guys that
waller when it was painted 20 years ago
it was fresh and new but you know what
it's peeling off the wall it's a
disgrace to this neighborhood we're
trying to rejuvenate clean the place up
and you try to get them to see that and
say is this so important to you that it
has to stay or could you have a
conversation about rheum isn't it
bill wolsey is one of northern ireland's
most successful business people
a self-made man he runs a string of
high-end hotels and pubs he grew up in a
working-class unionist area but his
parents were socialists i made it and i
have no clue how i made it um
some luck and some judgement um
but i
i went over to arsenal to play football
and that didn't work out and i got into
printing which i hated and then at night
school i went to college in westminster
and got into hospitality industry and
loved it and made a little bit of money
in in england and then came back to buy
a pub
that was run by paramilitaries we were
able to purchase this
um
this pub and we had sort of two years of
hell
um but
at that stage that new online was very
dark difficult days but we were
determined that a we wouldn't pay
protection and b
we would absolutely let everyone enter
our pub we didn't care about religion
politics but we did have uh we we wanted
them to respect our rules and sounds
pretty obvious now but was
difficult and that's safe
he says brexit is one way politicians
perpetuate divisions
because of the good friday agreement
most people couldn't countenance who
returned to a hard border on the island
of ireland
a quarter of a century of peace has
reduced a once fortified boundary to
this
an almost imperceptible line in the
tarmac
in its place a customs border was put in
the irish sea everybody knows here that
if you appeal to the national side on
the union aside that's pretty much split
40 40. it's the 20 percent in the middle
who absolutely are reconsidering
where this country should go
and they're looking at on the basis what
would be best for my children
do i still feel european how are we on
social progress
and where will i be economically it's no
longer driven by orange and grain today
tech and service companies have
relocated here the movie business has
taken off
shipbuilding and linen have gone and
many young people are just bored by
constantly harking back to history
benji wallace a 19 year old poet and
rapper tells me that for his work the
past is not prologue a lot of it isn't
it's not inspired by all of the
the conflict and the kind of division
it's about the fact that
i don't care about it and it's not
relevant really anymore not forgetting
the past
but letting it
letting us learn from it but not keep
acknowledging it
northern ireland's future whether to
remain part of the uk or to unite with
ireland is just one of the many things
that divide people here
unlike all the other social cultural
political economic and educational
divisions it's going to take time to
settle
but there's plenty of optimism too
take benji
unlike many of his generation he doesn't
want to leave northern ireland
but he does want things to change
i am resilient
days turn to months months turn to years
upon years we are all different this
wasted potential is turning our hopes
into fears this is the barrier never
acknowledged artists forced to leave
are we country is about to get weirder
if you don't truly believe in the youth
of the nation fill our frustrations
doubts and hopes cut us loose from the
industrial rope creative time bombs
about to explode we are young but you'd
better take notes we're a wild rock the
cultural boat we are strong keep this
nation afloat innovate because we're
ditching your cultural road